can I just go back to your other point
about the fact that uh we always put it
on men so I don't agree with that
because again I did a lot of research
into this so 90 of single motherhood
it's a woman so in a single parent home
it's a woman that is a single parent how
can you say that we're always putting it
on a man when women are the ones
stepping up for their kid so I'll tell
you you're right you're right ninety
percent of women are awarded custody
like I've actually talked to divorced
like lawyers about this they say they
love representing women in court it's
much easier for women than it is for men
I'm not saying it's easy either way